bad trip is on netflix the buzz is off
the charts it was released
last friday eric andre tiffany haddish
and this man lil rollhowery in the
hidden camera comedy
seth rogan just tweeted out we put his
tweet up if it wasn't so profane
but uh he talked about how dynamite it
is and little howery back here on the
rich eisen show how have you been sir
what's going on man what's going on with
you this thing is taking off to say the
least
i'm sure you must have been hearing
quite a bit about it yeah we uh
i think we surprised netflix they're
like wait a minute so the the movie with
the gorilla you know
this is our number one movie
but yeah it started it's a crazy buzz
and it continues to go on
which is so cool because we've been
sitting on it for a second so
for it to finally be out it feels good
for what to be doing as well
uh me eric and tiffany are constantly
texting and facetiming each other like
yo what's happening
what's happening is people can't get
enough of it and you said you've been
sitting on it for for
a little second but um eric andre said
it's taken
seven years to make this that's what he
said i think it took several years in
his process right
it took me we filmed it like 2018
and um so it just took a few years for
it to come out because we had like two
or three different
premiere dates over time so uh for
netflix be
to be the one to grab it's kind of a
full circle moment but it's it's so
it's so fun watching a movie that
everybody is just having fun with like
even like bad criticism is still
hysterical so it's like
bad critics are like the crews who hate
the movie they like hate it and it's so
they hate it so much
that the stuff they write is hysterical
like eric literally just posted a video
with just the bad reviews and it's so
funny
well i mean clearly you know um
it's a hidden camera movie i mean it's
it's it's a prank show made into a
full-length film
and um how are you pranking people i
mean are you comfortable with it or
or did you feel bad that you what people
that you were pranking at any point in
time where you you felt the need to
maybe pull back pull the plug on
anything or
you just you live for stuff like this
what is that no i mean it was more or
less like honestly these weren't
mean pranks and the pranks were mostly
on us so
it was just watching people react to us
which i think that's what's interesting
about the movie
you see a lot of people helping us like
trying to make sure we're okay
so uh that's and just following the
character like i'm not like oh yeah i'd
like to do pranks but i love character
work
so what all i did really was just fall
into character to make sure
people took my character seriously so
they wouldn't know this was a prank
so it's as much as i had to black out in
and where i had to believe this stuff
was really happening
that's what made that was easy for us to
bait those people in so what's your
favorite one
from the film little ralph you know some
it's one that wasn't released yet and i
think we go releasing
maybe this week or next week is
we did an exorcism right where uh eric
character gets possessed by the devil
okay so we had like had this hotel room
had the walls was bleeding and
he uh he levitated at one point so we
had this priest come here right i don't
know if this dude went to preschool
maybe for this he's like man
i swear i gotta get the devil out of
somebody he was so
serious right he's giving me like bible
scriptures he made me hold his phone
like every time he asked me to say
something i was saying but i was cursed
so he would get mad like no no no you
can't say that like that
like the hell out of it i was like get
the f out of the devil
he's like no no you can't say f so it
was he was so serious
when he left he had to track him down
because he left cocky he was like yeah i
did that
that's right you were possessed and i i
delivered you man
me it was so cool he was so serious that
it made
it to wonder it just didn't fit into
what the movie is but
right he's gonna put it out there anyway
because it's one of the craziest pranks
i've ever been a part of so it didn't
make the final cut of the film but
you're gonna just throw it out there
where on netflix or social media or
where
were you popping that up we're gonna
throw it on social media
and we're gonna throw a pry on the uh
netflix youtube channel i can't wait for
this
so it's it's so exciting i mean what's
it like working with two
uh lead pipe wielding professional
comedian funny people uh
lorel you've done obviously quite a bit
of that in your career but uh
eric andre and tiffany haddish who
couldn't be uh
more on fire in her career right now
what about that
but you know tip is one of my best
friends and that's you know we've worked
on several things together and eric is
one of my good friends that's what made
this special to be honest which is that
we're all actually friends and a lot of
times when you get a chance to work with
people you actually really care about or
really respect and they've got love for
it's just like it's just laughed all the
time i think that's why when people
watch it you know some people yeah
chemistry everybody's chemistry is
really good but i'm like well
we actually like each other
[Laughter]
you know so it made for a really good
movie because all of us had great
chemistry but literally we all took our
characters really seriously
and i think that's what made it work
honestly bad trip on netflix it's been
out there for
about a week and check it out uh well
not about a week for a week check it out
on netflix little roweri how are you
here on the rich eisen show
so what's um you know obviously you know
working with people that you love
what's it like trying to beat people
that you love off the dribble in an
nba all-star game what's that like for
you
well let me two things two things happen
okay yeah you know
as everybody know i said i would have 16
and five i've really talked about that
at one time
so i played the celebrity game i had 16
and five yes
when we start we got the line right live
live
i felt the twinge of my knee and in that
moment i said is it worth telling my
achilles
to cross over common it really is
you know i mean is
i trained for weeks right to get ready
for this like that's where the moment is
like
what are you doing man you are a actor
and a comedian
brother if you tell your achilles you
won't be able to work
is it worth it and i was like nope and
it wasn't so i had to like
my highlights of me tripping over my
foot and they kept replaying that
and i threw one really amazing pass yes
uh
ronnie 2k like that i just gave
everybody a taste of it but i was like
that was it
like i want to coach for them they bring
me back i'm coaching
well it looks like to me though that you
you're still you still have
some ability on the floor that you need
to tap i just saw a photograph of you
and
common and famous loss uh you know going
i guess
it seems like a jump ball that you're
trying to create right here that you
you know i i assume you would have won
that jump ball oh that sounds good
brother i
i i'm telling every real grown man like
i still work out i get on my pillow time
like all the other people 40 and up do
and i take my boxing classes but i don't
spar with nobody i just
i just practice that is it for me i've
got i'm done
that was my moment to say hey my mind i
thought i still i'm like i can't do this
i'm going to hurt myself anything
what do you like on the peloton lorell i
mean because it strikes me like
are you somebody who who would who does
take the
uh the the leaderboard no no
the leaderboard or does take the the the
words of encouragement from
from the coach uh do you take those you
just scream back at them like you know
shut up
first stickers doesn't mean whoever does
that are lunatics actually
now what i've done is you know you could
turn the music down
on on your bike and just have more of
the instructor voice so what i do is i
have
her voice because tune day is really the
only person classes i take
and i just play my own music so i got
like a bunch of different playlists i
have
for my peloton rides i got like a gospel
playlist i got a rocky full soundtrack
playlist i got
like and that's when i really get it in
you when you when i ride to the rocky
soundtrack and there's no easy way out
comes on
i get i go crazy you know like there's
no wheezy way out man
so that's where you so if if it's time
to go up a hill
you that's where you want that
soundtrack to hit
that song so what you're saying a
particular song because it was one of my
favorite scenes
in rocky fours with the specimens of
stone he gets in that car
that car was going fast and just driving
and he's just reminiscing about him and
apollo and everything that happened yeah
and my mother is singing the best i said
baby baby you can share
this tear because i know how it feels
and stuff let me just
i don't know those words don't even make
sense but
rocky iv soundtrack so the rocky
soundtrack rocky ii rocky
iii no good rocky iv is the one rocky
folk voucher i mean you got
living in america with james brown oh
yeah he's kind of he shoots at this
eddie murphy at the end of eddie murphy
eat your heart out because i guess he
gets out of eddie murphy building sunday
live
that is the craziest thing like
why did you shout out eddie murphy and
live in america he just said anniversary
eat your heart out
that's all he said little harry here on
the rich eisen show
so just to sum up here um
and put a button on the nba all-star
game from chicago in 2020 because the
last time you were on
we were talking about your preparation
and you did give us that stat line that
you were calling your shot okay
had you not tweaked your knee in the
layup line
you would have had that stat line you
would have crossed over common you would
have done all of what you were intending
to do that's what you're saying to me
right now i could have dominated that
guy if
if if i didn't feel like uh i was gonna
hurt myself
i could have literally dominate what
steven a the coach was stephen a who's
your coach
who's the kid coach but he man let me
tell you something
yeah steven they're one of those coaches
like you you don't want him teaching
like coaching kids right because i'm a
grown man
and at some point i remember just
looking at him because i've continued to
believe in me no more
and i just wanted to go back in again so
i'm like stand up
i'm like do it i'll be like actually on
the satellite cheering everybody come on
y'all we can do this
hopefully the ex will be back in but i
was just looking at
it it's a look he would
are you telling me that stephen a smith
benched you in the
nba all-star celebrity game of 2020. so
your time
i remember him looking at all of us
because we we got destroyed he was like
yeah i made a mistake
i picked the wrong group of guys to do
this with
oh god
oh my god and you want to get back in
and he was
having none of it you could not you
wasn't you're nailed to the bench
you were you were back i took the last
shot of the game
i thought it was gonna be that one shiny
moment march madness shot
right i took the street over there like
darius now
it's like one shot of the movement i
tried to do it it was like nah
it didn't happen over darius miles
you're you shut up
no no no no he gave me the ball trying
to shoot over cue actually okay
[ __ ] all right and so it didn't happen
didn't no splash
no no did it didn't it didn't happen
yeah it was it was yeah
and it was like darius miles boy that
that brave wig like it was so funny i
was like you got this braised wig
it was so crazy stephen a smith is like
no
dnp cd did not play coach's decision he
didn't even speak to none of us when we
left he didn't come to the locker room
all right we gotta straight through i'm
not lying about that i'm telling you i
forgot true he just left
they had like gifts for him and
everything he was like i'm good i'm gone
i'm going straight to the airport i'm
good i'm gone
all right oh my gosh
uh all right before i let you go your
next project's fatherhood with kevin
hart on netflix coming up june 18th
so that i i'm going to make a note of
that that's going to be great
uh um yeah what's that about i guess the
the the title is
somewhat self-explanatory but you can
i'll give you the floor on that
yeah it is about fathers it's basically
about this this young uh
young man who loses his wife um um and
when she was having their child and now
it's up to him to raise his little girl
on his own
and you know everybody kind of don't
really think he can do it but you know
he proves them wrong
but you know kevin does that this is a
drama for kevin and kevin
kevin kills i think this is one of his
best
i honestly believe one his best
performance i've ever seen a man
isn't it's a lot of heart and it's going
it's a bit of a tear jerky but it's also
it's
like i'm i'm the comic relief in it in a
way so it's really funny too so it's
just gonna be a beautiful movie to watch
with your family actually okay make a
note of that again june 18th and then
free guy with ryan reynolds in theaters
august 13th he is a funny dude right now
i can't wait for y'all to finally see
this movie like we all like
like ryan did a really funny video to
announce this new date
because we did we did this like three
times you know so he's like all right
look yeah this is
and they just cut them off uh but this
movie is
so good it's action-packed and i'm very
excited for it to be going to theater so
uh we'll see what happens it's just you
know between the movies and you know i
got the game show
uh small fortune nbc it premieres may
31st
and the sports show host not a sports
show on a fico uh app so
i'm grinding you know all right you
definitely are little rel
as always uh and i always enjoy our
chats on this show
uh are always a lot of fun thanks for
doing this congrats on bad trip i look
forward to seeing that uh
that added extra coming out where you
know good job on you
pranking a priest well done um
i cannot wait to get out y'all gotta see
how cocky this priest is though
well he thinks he's dealing with the
devil little ralph
he had me hold his phone he said hold my
phone recorded i'm like what
did he just
[Laughter]
what was it like when you had to let
them know that that was all a gag
we never he just left like like stephen
in the all-star game just get out they
had to
chase his brother drive down to he just
he was so
into the cockiness of it and i didn't
want to break because it was so crazy to
me right
i was like all right
he didn't want the gift bag he didn't
want anything so you just get out
okay he went straight to his church like
i told y'all
i'm the
[Laughter]
bad trip on netflix has been out a week
with little rel eric andre and tiffany
haddish little rel here on the rich
eisen show you take care of yourself
let's do this again soon
thank you man thanks for having me
always that was a lot of fun my gosh
little relfar four on twitter number
four and
at comedian lil rel on instagram
now on a scale of one to ten
right on a scale of one to ten one where
it's not surprising at all
ten it's totally off the charts i can't
believe
this actually happened one again is like
not surprising
ten is totally surprising right okay put
it all together
scale of one to ten stephen a smith
livid with the celebrities for not
pulling their weight
in the celebrity all-star game under his
coaching employee
and storming off and staring down lil
rel
for not giving it his all he may have
not
known or may have known that he tweaked
his knee during warm-ups
scale it wants to send one not
surprising ten totally surprising what
is it
one one we now must get stephen a smith
on this
one thousand percent and i only want to
talk about
this forget about it i don't care about
any sport yet master's week i don't care
nfl draft nba nope
i only want to talk about that what
happened during the all-star game yes
didn't get the gift bag don't need it
don't want it just let me have it he's
like he's like singletary yeah
don't need it is that gift bag still
just hanging out in there it is chicago
locker room that's stephen
a yeah some assistant jack that isn't
that great
i kind of like that that's the way i
want that story to be told
i truly want the story to be told that
way yeah me too
that was phenomenal the priest though
the priest i told you i cannot wait to
watch it
hold my phone hold my well i'd be
recording record this
record
that priest was so cocky cocky priest
and then the priest just dipped and he's
like i'm out i gotta imagine though if
you
you know feel like you talked to god i
would be pretty cocky yeah and get out
that's a mic job yeah that would be
pretty cocky too hey you watched all the
way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here